so i discovered i had messy hair in cia
because i used to uh i used to go muge
we called it muj i used to go mujahideen
style big burly beard and crazy wacky
hair yeah because an ambiguously brown
guy with a big beard and long hair
can go anywhere in the world without
anyone
even noticing him they either think that
he's a janitor or they think that he's
like
some forgotten part of history but
nobody ever thinks that that guy is a
spy so it was the perfect
for me it was
one of my favorite
uh
disguises it's what's known as a level
two disguise one of my favorite
disguises to don was just
dilapidated brown guy
uh can you actually we'll just take a
million tangent what what's the
skies
uh what what's uh what are the different
levels of disguise what are the
disguises yeah there's three levels of
disguise by and large level one is what
we also know what we also call light
disguise so that's essentially you put
on sunglasses and a ball cap and
and that's a disguise you look different
than you normally look
so it's just different enough that
someone who's never seen you before
someone who literally has to see you
just from a picture on the internet they
may not recognize you it's why you see
celebrities walk around with ball caps
and oversized jackets and baseball hats
because they just need to not look like
they look in the tabloid or not look
like they look in tv
that's level one
uh let me jump from level one to level
three level three is all of your
prosthetics all the stuff you see in
mission impossible your fake ears your
fake faces your fat suits your stilts
inside your leg your feet all that's
level three whenever they make any kind
of prosthetic disguise
that's a level three disguise because
prosthetics are
very damning
if you are caught with a prosthetic if
you're caught
wearing a sudden wearing a baseball hat
and sunglasses nobody's going to say
you're a spy but when you're caught with
a custom-made you know nose
prosthetic that changes the way your
face looks or when someone pops out a
fake jaw and they see that your top
teeth don't look like they did
in this prosthetic then all of a sudden
you've got some very difficult questions
to ask or to answer so level three is
extremely dangerous level one is not
dangerous level two is long-term
disguise
level 2 is all the things that you can
do to permanently change the way you
look for a long period of time so that
whether
you're aggressed in the street or
whether someone breaks into your hotel
room or whatever
it's real
so maybe that's uh maybe you get a
tattoo maybe you cut your hair short
maybe you grow your hair long maybe you
go bald maybe you start wearing glasses
well glasses are technically a
prosthetic but
you can
you if you have teeth pulled if you gain
20 pounds really gain 20 pounds or lose
15 pounds whatever you might do all of
that's considered level two it's
designed for a long-term mission
so that
people believe you are who you say you
are in that disguise a lot of that is
physical characteristics right what
about like um you know what actors do
which is the
method acting yeah the method acting
sort of
developing a back story in your own mind
and then you start
um
you know pretending that you host the
podcast and
teach at a university and then do
research and so on just so that people
can believe yeah that you're not
actually uh agent uh what is that part
of the disguise levels or no so yes
disguise has to do with physical
character traits that's what a disguise
is what you're talking about is known as
a cover legend
when you go undercover what you claim to
be who you claim to be that's called
your legend your cover legend every
disguise would theoretically have
its own cover legend
even if it's just to describe why you're
wearing what you're wearing it's all a
cover
so the method acting this is a fantastic
point that i don't get to make very
often so i'm glad you asked the
difference between cia officers in the
field and method actors is that method
actors try to become
the character they try to
shed all vestiges of who they really are
and become the character and that's part
of what makes them so amazing but it's
also part of what
like
makes them mentally unstable over long
periods of time it's part of what feeds
their depression their anxiety their
personal issues because they lose sight
of who they really are
field officers don't get that luxury we
have to always always remember
we are a covert cia intelligence officer
collecting secrets in the field we have
to remember that so we're taught
a very specific skill to
compartmentalize
our true self
separately but make that true self
the true identity so then we can still
live and act and and
effectively carry out our cover legend
without ever losing
sight without ever losing that compass
true north of who we actually are and
then we can compartmentalize and secure
all the information that we need retain
it remember it but then return to our
true self
when we when we get back to a position
of safety is it possible to do that so
i i just have kind of anecdotal evidence
for myself i really try to be the exact
same person in all conditions which
makes it very easy
like if you're not lying
it makes it very easy to
first of all to exist but also to
communicate a kind of authenticity and
genuineness which i think is really
important like trust and integrity
around trust is extremely important to
me it's the thing that opens doors
and maintains relationships
and
i tend to think
like when i was in ukraine so many doors
just opened to the like very high
security
areas and everywhere else too like i've
just interacted with some incredible
people without any kind of concerns
you know who's this guy is he gonna
spread it you know all that kind of
stuff and they i tend to believe that
you're able to communicate a
trustworthiness somehow if if you just
are who you are and
and i think i suppose method actors are
trying to achieve that by becoming
something and they can
i just feel like there is very subtle
cues
that are extremely difficult to fake
like you really have to become that
person
be that person but you're saying
as a cia agent you have to remember that
you are
there to collect information do you
think that gives you away
so
one of the flaws in your argument
is that you keep referring to how you
feel i feel this i feel that i feel like
this i feel like that
that
feeling
is a predictable
character trait of all human beings it's
a pink matter
we call it pink matter it's a cognitive
trait
you are not alone in trusting your
feelings all people trust their feelings
but because
what cia teaches us is how to
systematically create artificial
relationships
where we're the one in control of the
source that is giving us intelligence
and the core element to being able to
control a relationship is understanding
the pink matter truth of feelings
what all people feel becomes their point
of view on what reality is so when you
understand and you learn how to
manipulate what people feel
then you can essentially direct them to
feel any way you want them to feel so if
you want them to feel like they can
trust you
you can make them feel that way if you
want them to feel like you're a good guy
or a bad guy if you want them to feel
like they should give you secrets even
though their government tells them not
to you can do that there are men who
make women feel like they love they love
them and just so that the woman will
sleep with them there are women who make
men feel like they love them just so the
men will give them their money
manipulation is a as a core behavioral
trait of all the human species because
we all understand to some level how
powerful feelings are but feelings are
not the same thing as logical rational
thoughts they're two different sides of
the brain
what cia teaches us how to do is
systematically
tap into
the right side emotional side of the
brain so that we can
quickly get past all of the stuff you
were just saying all of the
well don't you have to be convincing and
don't you have to really know your story
and don't you have to be able to defend
it don't you have to have authenticity
and don't you have to have uh genuine uh
genuine feelings yes all those things
are true
if you're having a genuine relationship
but in an artificial relationship
there's ways to bypass all of that and
get right to the heart of making someone
feel comfortable and safe i guess the
question i i'm asking and the thing i
was
implying is that creating an artificial
relationship was an extremely difficult
skill
to accomplish the level
like how good i am at being me
and creating a feeling in another person
that i create
for you to do that artificially that's
gotta be you gotta be
my sense is you gotta be really damn
good at that kind of thing i i would
venture to say
it's i mean
i don't know how to measure how
difficult the thing is but especially
when you're communicating with people
whose job depends on forming trusting
relationships they're gonna smell
[ __ ]
um and to to get get past that [ __ ]
detector is tough it's a tough skill
well it's interesting so i would i would
say that
or maybe i'm wrong actually on that i
would say that once you understand the
system it's not that hard it makes a lot
of sense but i would also say that to
you to your exact point you are right
that people smell [ __ ]
people smell [ __ ] but here's the
thing
if you come in smelling like
goat [ __ ]
you still smell like [ __ ] but you don't
smell like [ __ ]
so they don't count you out right away
and if you come in smelling like
rotten tomatoes or if you come in
smelling like lavender or if you come in
smelling like vanilla or if you come in
without any smell at all all that
matters is that you don't smell like
[ __ ] here's the thing that's that's
one of the secret sauces of cia
when you look and act like a spy people
think you're a spy
if you look and act in any other way you
know what they never ever think you are
a spy
they might think you're an idiot they
might think you're uh
they might think you're trailer trash
they might think that you're a
a migrant worker but they never think
you're a spy yeah and that's what's that
lesson in everyday life
is immensely powerful if you're trying
to if you're trying to take your boss's
job as long as you don't ever look like
the bot the employee who's trying to
take the boss's job the boss is focused
on all the employees who are trying to
take his job everybody's prioritizing
whether they know it or not the goal is
to just not be the one that they're
targeting target them without them
knowing you're targeting them so people
just
when they meet you they put you in a bin
and if you want to avoid being put in a
particular bin just don't act like the
person that would be
uh just show some kind of
characteristics that bin you in some
other way exactly right you have to be
in a bin just choose the bin
so
you
knowing these methods when you talk to
people especially in civilian life how
do you know
who's lying to you and not
that gets to be
more into the trained skill side of
things there's body cues
there's micro expressions i'm not a big
fan of
i don't believe that micro expressions
alone do anything i also don't believe
that micro expressions without a without
an effective baseline do anything so
don't for a second think that i'm
all the people out there pitching that
you can tell if someone's lying to you
just by looking at their face it's all
it's all baloney in my world that's
baloney like the way you move your eyes
or something like that without knowing a
baseline without knowing for that
individual for that individual then you
actually don't know and an individual's
baseline is based on education culture
life experience you name it right so
this is huge but when you combine
facial expressions with body movements
body language nonverbal cues and you add
on top of that effective elicitation
techniques that you are in control of
now you have a more robust
platform to tell if someone's lying to
you so there there's like a
set of like interrogation
trajectories you can go down that can
help you
figure out a person technically their
interview interview
like this concepts correct because an
interrogation an interrogation is
something very different than an
interview and in the world of
professionals and interrogation is very
different what's the difference the the
nature of how relaxed the thing is or
what so in an interrogation
there's a clear pattern of dominance
there's no equality got it also there's
no escape you are there until the
interrogator is done with you right
anybody who's ever been reprimanded by
mom and dad knows what an interrogation
feels like anybody's ever been called
into the principal's office or the
boss's office that's what interrogation
feels like you don't leave until the
boss says you can leave and you're there
to say to answer questions the boss asks
questions an interview is an equal
exchange of ideas
you are in control of this interview
for sure but if we were having coffee
i could take control if i wanted to take
control if i wanted to ask you personal
questions i would if i wanted to talk to
you about your background i could
why am i in control of this interview
exactly because the person in control is
the person asking questions
oh i'm sitting here as you've spoken
about
uh my power here is i'm the quiet one
listening
you're exactly right guess where this
conversation goes yeah anywhere you
choose to take it because you're the one
asking questions every time i answer a
question i am creating a pattern of
obedience to you
which subliminally subconsciously makes
me that much more apt to answer your
questions of course you can always turn
that and ask start asking me questions
it should you know
so but you're saying that there's
through this
through conversation you can call it
interviewing you can start to
you can start to see
um
see cracks
in the story of the person
and the degree to which they exaggerate
or lie or
uh
to see how much they could be trusted
that kind of stuff what i'm saying is
that through a conversation you develop
a baseline right like even just in the
last the last the first part of our
conversation i've been able to create
some baseline elements about you
you've been able to create baseline
elements about me maybe they're just not
front of mind
from those baselines now we can push
through more intentional questions
to test
got it to test whether or not the person
is being truthful because they're
operating within their baseline or if
you are triggering
uh sensitivities outside of their
baseline and then you can start to see
their tells
that's fascinating yeah baseline like uh
even even like yeah the tells right the
the eye contact like you you've probably
already formed a bass line that i i have
trouble making eye contact and so like
so if you ask me difficult questions and
i'm not making eye contact maybe that's
not a good signal of me lying or
whatever correct because i always have
trouble making eye contact stuff like
that that's really fascinating the
majority of your eye movement is to the
right yeah my your right my left yes
right which is usually someone who's if
you ask micro expressionists that's
someone who's referencing fact yeah
that's not necessarily what's happening
for you because you're pulling concepts
out of the air so it's also a place
where you reference something other than
fact it's a place for you to find
creativity yeah so if i just thought
that you were lying because you look up
and to the right
i would be wrong that's so fascinating
and a lot of that has to do with like
habits that are formed and all those
kinds of things or maybe some right hand
left hand type of situation right-eye
dominance yeah right that's gonna make
you look to the right is this a science
or an art it's a bit of both i would say
that like all good art art is taught
from a foundation of skills
and those skills are
are
played are taught in a very structured
manner and then the way that you
use the skills after that that's more of
the artistic grace
so i've always called espionage an art
spying is an art being able to hack
human beings is an art but it's all
based in a foundation of science you
still have to learn how to mix the color
palette and use certain brushes
do you think of that as as a kind of
the study of human psychology is that
what a psychologist does or
psychiatrists what from this process
have you learned
about human nature
human nature i mean i suppose the answer
to that could be a book
but
uh it probably will be a book i'll save
you that yeah but
sort of is there
is there things that are surprising
about human nature surprising to other
us civilians
that you could speak to yes one thing is
extremely surprising about human nature
um which is funny because that's not the
answer i would have said so i'm glad
that you clarified this specific
question the thing that's surprising
about human nature is that human beings
long
like
in their soul there's like a painful
longing
to be with other people
and that's really surprising because you
we all want to pretend like we're strong
we all want to pretend like we're
you know independent we all want to
pretend like we are
the masters of our destiny but
what's truly consistent in all people is
this
like longing to commune
with others like us
my
my more practical answer about what i've
learned to be the truth is that people
human nature is predictable
and that predictability is what gives
people an incredible advantage over
other people
but that's not the surprising piece i
mean even when cia taught me that human
nature is predictable it just made sense
i was like oh yeah it makes sense
but what i never ever anticipated was
no matter where i've been in the world
no matter who i've talked to no matter
what
socioeconomic bracket is that longing
man it hurts
loneliness sucks
and togetherness feels good even if
you're together with someone you know
isn't the right person it still feels
better than being alone i mean that's
such a deep truth you speak to and and
i i could talk about that for a long
time there is i mean through these
conversations in general whether it's
being recorded or not
i
hunger
to discovering the other person that
longing you strip away the other things
and then you share in the longing for
that connection
and i particularly also have detected
that
in
people from all walks of life yes
including
people that others might identify as
evil yeah or
hard
as uh completely
cold
it's there it's there they've hardened
themselves
in their search
and who knows what dark place their
brain is in their heart is in
but that
that longing is still there even if it's
an ember it's there
it's the reason why
why
in world war one and world war ii
you know enemy combatants still shared
cigarettes on the front lines
you know during periods of holidays or
bad weather or whatever else because
that human connection man it
triumphs overall see that's
in part of what i refer to when i say
love because i feel like if uh like
political leaders and
people in conflict at the small scale
and large scale were
able
to tune into that longing to seek in
each other that basic longing for human
connection a lot of problems could be
solved
but of course
it's difficult because uh it's a it's a
game of chicken
because uh if you open yourself up to
reveal that longing for connection with
others
people can hurt you well i would go a
step farther and i would say that taking
the connection away
punishing
penalizing people by removing the
connection
is a powerful tool
and that's what we see that's why we
send people to jail that's why we put
economic sanctions on countries that's
why we ground our children and send them
to their rooms we are penalizing them
whether we know it or not we're
using punitive damage by taking away
that basic human connection that longing
for
for community
you